well simon hello um thank you for doing
this math olympic show here at the
school um
right with the kids i think they loved
it um for those who you know people who
haven't experienced or heard of maths
olympics do you mind giving us like in
one sentence
what is it why do you do it what it's
all about ah
well it's matt's comedy
uh which is great because it's a term
that you know uh
intrigues and perplexes well maths
component is not really uh i mean people
say to me i was i'm equal uh parts
uh confused and terrified yeah
there's a venn diagram where it's like
confused and terrified and then the
crossover is like maths yeah so confused
confused and terrified and then in the
middle it's like how i feel about math
and that's how most people feel
unfortunately because they've had such
bad experience so you described this so
nice comedy so but why do you do that
well i mean
well the whole motivation for the show
was ironically is not because i wanted
to come into schools
so this is like being an amazing thing
that's happened out of it but it was all
because
i
got to uni wanting to be a physics or be
a physicist
so you enrolled in bachelor science yeah
i did a bachelor of science yeah yeah so
i was i was a good kid i was like a i
was i was always good at science and
maths and i was always really interested
in um science and maths so i was like
really interested in einstein's theory
of relativity like
i was obsessed like my nickname was
albie they called me alby short for
albert einstein you had crazy there too
to kind of no no not back then i was
like okay i was a nerd like comb down
yeah you won't get into that it's uh
yeah i'm still a nerd i'm a transcendent
nerd
i was really really interested in it and
i think even though there were there
might have i mean i was really high up
in the in the in the class
and i but there were some smarter guys
and there's always smarter people
but it's my enthusiasm
like i don't think anyone had a level of
enthusiasm that i had
and uh and it's great because that's
really makes the difference and so um so
when i got to uni i
i um you know this was my dream to
become a physicist
um and i was really shocked because when
i got there
the
people were the people who were teaching
me
like they weren't social like it was all
very insular and they went to their
rooms you mean like the lecturers and
professors yeah yeah yeah there was all
they were just they were just not
talking sociable people
and i and i just distinctly remember
thinking like i don't want to i don't
want to be like that for someone like
you that must have been a massive sort
of yeah it was it was it was a massive
disconnect yeah yeah
and then what i discovered was just kind
of just being you know uni is one of the
best things about uni is the fact that
you're just there with great people so
that's that's the thing for me is like
university is a gathering of people and
whatever makes it work be it you know
fees or whatever or whatever you know
it's just the gathering of these
awesome people in your early 20s and
everyone's like vibrant and
and so the people i ended up making
friends with were the art students
because you know they had enough time
off yeah like two contact hours but i i
just love character and personality and
what you were into yeah and just like
the communication like you know it's i
don't i'm speaking about this in
retrospect now but you know it was
i was learning about
communication like sitting down and
talking and having a conversation and
being funny and witty and uh you know
like being imaginative
i i would you know i think part of me
was thinking i'm wasting time but now
it's not i actually think it's vitally
important because
um that was something i lacked and i
really wanted
and and i also had this other part of me
which i was really interested in and
what happened was the people i was
hanging out with
hated it
so you had to try to reconcile these
yeah exactly besides yourself yeah i was
trying to reconcile two sides of myself
but also i think i was i was just trying
to i i was kind of i couldn't understand
how these people who were very
intelligent just hated maths it was just
like don't talk to me about maths i mean
you know who i'm talking about there's
so many people like that we're not
talking about just you know um
uh this is like you know we're talking
about like phds and all these sort of
people that go on to do great things
they have no relationship with
mathematics whatsoever and they've just
consigned themselves to the fact that
they're an art of humanities person and
my brain doesn't work not even on the
table it's not even on the table no and
that really shocked me because you know
it got to the point where
um
my girlfriend at the time she was a
visual artist she you know she drew and
stuff and she was kind of interested in
maths as well but it's it's just so many
people just hated it and and whenever i
try to bring up stuff they would just
like not even give me a go like they
just start making jokes
um
and so um and this is you know this is
before the time of qi i think a lot of
things have happened since then that
have changed but you know back in the
90s definitely back then it was like
nerd as a derogatory term
no there was nothing like cool about it
it had no it the whole
type of thing where it's like oh that's
its own yeah people can respect that
it's anything that hadn't no no no
because google hadn't kicked in yet so
uh yeah so so anyway so i i
took it upon myself because i was
interested in performing and uh and i
sort of dabbled a bit but i kind of
thought
you know well part of me thought i can't
go and do
jokes about maccas like i'm not going to
be a tradie
because like the australian scene you
know if you go there everyone was doing
kind of the same thing which i kind of
ironically again because of my maths it
was like i recognized that there was
this formula
that not a formula an algorithm really
people were following you know it's like
whatever so if it's an ethnicity thing
so like italians are talking about being
italian and greek and vietnamese and
muslim and whatever and it's just like
guys you know it's
we can do better than this or it's like
it's you know you kind of this has been
done before it was it was kind of a
crowded space and it was just over and
over again the same
tropes and all that
it was
sure it's crowded but i just think
people didn't understand
the fact that all these people didn't
understand that you know why go and copy
someone else you really this there's
just so many ideas out there that are
yet to be discovered you have to your
job is to come up with something new and
go explore see what hasn't been done
yeah yeah yeah and so and so there was
part of that in my mind but also i i
you know i was looking down the you know
the paths of comedy but then it was like
i realized well
if you tell a joke people will listen
and jokes are complicated things and
they're abstract they really are
abstract because if you think about it
i'm making you laugh with noises
like noises coming out of my mouth if i
did it in a language you don't
understand whatever
whatever that might be
like you just might you know you might
think oh that sounds funny but you don't
understand you don't have the meaning
attached to it so it's this really
bizarre thing it's very abstract
actually you have to be quiet clever to
comprehend and appreciate a joke that's
right yeah yeah and the and the joke
maker is doing this dance and making
this thing because the whole thing about
a joke working is that there's a there's
a
realization so there's something that
triggers in your head that creates
enjoyment and guess what that's what
happens when you solve women
it's the same enjoyment that click which
most people do not usually connect well
people don't have any idea yeah and i
mean you know like in my show i talk
about pythagoras theorem
because you know i've met engineers that
don't even know how to prove pythagoras
i mean not instantly i mean sure they
could sit down and work it out
but
for me that was just incredibly
important like why do these things work
why are there these patterns what do
these patterns mean
you know it's
for that i'm a mathematician i'm
interested